karl y trato de resolver una ecuación
paso por paso tenemos aquí la adecuación
y por acá tenemos paso por paso como
resolvió esta ecuación y después por acá
nos dicen que encontremos en donde se
equivocó carlin
así es que veamos que hizo carling que
empezó con esta ecuación 7 a es igual a
28 pero luego karl y divide el lado
izquierdo entre a y el lado derecho
entre 7 pero eso está muy extraño no
porque todo lo que le hagas a un lado de
la ecuación se lo tienes que hacer al
otro también
si quieres dividir el lado izquierdo
entre a entonces también tienes que
dividir el lado derecho entre a o al
revés si quieres dividir el lado derecho
entre 7 entonces también tienes que
dividir el lado izquierdo entre 7 así es
que carly se equivocó en el paso 1 en el
paso 1 que ya vimos en donde se equivocó
karl y ahora qué cosa debió de haber
hecho karli en esta situación pues bueno
lo más razonable es que si karli quería
resolver esta ecuación quiere encontrar
cuánto vale
así es que lo más lógico sería dividir
ambos lados de la ecuación entre 7 y así
nos quedaría del lado izquierdo
simplemente una a y del lado derecho 4 y
entonces a es igual a 4 y ya se resolvió
la ecuación pero bueno vamos a checar
nuestra respuesta
muy bien vamos con otro ejercicio 30
trato de resolver una ecuación paso por
paso tenemos aquí la ecuación y el
procedimiento de trent y después nos
dicen encuentra donde se equivocó 30 así
es que han estado ocurriendo muchos
errores algebraicos pero bueno tenemos
aquí kg entre 3 es igual a 4 entre 3
así es que pues vamos a ver qué hizo 30
en el paso 1 cae del lado izquierdo
empezamos con g entre 3 y por aquí 30
multiplicó por 3 mientras que en el lado
derecho
empezamos con cuatro tercios cuatro
tercios y treinta multiplicó por un
tercio
así es que otra vez como en el ejercicio
pasado estamos haciendo las cosas
distintas
a estos dos lados cuando se supone que
deberíamos estar haciendo exactamente lo
mismo
si hacemos dos cosas distintas no se va
a preservar la igualdad y estas dos
cosas ya no van a ser iguales
si tenemos kg entre 3 es igual a 4 entre
3 si estas dos cosas son iguales pero
después multiplicamos esta parte por 3 y
esta otra parte por un tercio entonces
esto ya no va a ser igual porque si a
una cosa la multiplicamos por 3 eso nos
va a quedar más grande que si a esa
misma cosa la multiplicamos por un
tercio y entonces no se va a preservar
la igualdad así es que si quieres que se
preserven esta igualdad si multiplicas
por 3 de un lado tienes que multiplicar
por 3 del otro lado también o si lo que
quieres es multiplicar por un tercio
entonces también tienes que multiplicar
a esta parte por un tercio así es que
sabemos que hubo un error en el paso 1
aunque ahí vamos a verificar la
respuesta
ahora vamos con este ejercicio lynn
trato de resolver una ecuación paso por
paso tenemos por aquí la ecuación 12 es
igual a p más 6.2 y en el primer paso
del lado izquierdo tenemos 12 más 6.2
así es que lynn sumó 6.2 del lado
izquierdo y del lado derecho tenemos p
más 6.2 este 6.2 es este mismo 6.2 de
por acá pero luego tenemos menos 6.2 así
es que de este lado acaba de restar 6.2
como podemos ver es exactamente el mismo
número 6.2 pero del lado izquierdo lo
está sumando mientras que del lado
derecho lo está restando así es que pues
no le está haciendo lo mismo a los dos
lados de la igualdad
si quiere sumar 6.2 del lado izquierdo
de la igualdad entonces también tienes
que sumar 6.2 del lado derecho
si lo que quieres es restar 6.2 del lado
derecho entonces pues también tienes que
restar 6.2 del lado izquierdo así es que
hemos visto muchos errores en el paso 1
vamos a verificar la respuesta
como que ya nos debería de salir un
ejercicio donde el error estuviera en el
paso 2 no pero bueno
alana trató de resolver una ecuación
paso por paso la ecuación es 4 c igual a
12 y alan a lo que hizo fue dividir el
lado izquierdo entre 4 y el lado derecho
multiplicarlo por 4 pero eso está mal
porque si divides entre 4 el lado
izquierdo entonces tienes que dividir
entre 4 el lado derecho
así es que alan a se equivocó en el paso
bueno
hagamos otro de estos ejercicios tenemos
por aquí n 12 igual a 18.3 y empezamos
con el n 12 y después rico lo que hizo
fue restarle 12 al lado izquierdo de
esta igualdad entonces lo que tiene que
haber hecho rico es restarle 12 al lado
derecho también
si lo hizo entonces este paso de aquí
está muy bien bueno entonces continuemos
tenemos n más 12 menos 12 y n 12 menos
12 es simplemente n y bueno de hecho esa
es la razón por la que rico restó 12
para que nos quedará simplemente la n
del lado izquierdo de la igualdad y
ahora veamos qué pasa en el lado derecho
tenemos 18 puntos 3 menos 12
pues 1812 es 6 entonces por aquí
deberíamos de tener 6.3 y tenemos 5.7
así es que fue un error de aritmética en
el paso número dos a ver veamos
y listo ya terminamos